was this Collision itself an accident on
Russia's behalf and is the U.S
responding as such
um so you know we are continuing to
assess exactly what happened but I think
based on the actions of the Russian
Pilots it's clear that it was unsafe
unprofessional
um and I think the actions speak for
themselves what we what we saw again
were fighter aircraft dumping fuel in
front of this UAV and then getting so
close to the aircraft that it actually
damaged the propeller on the MQ-9 we we
assess that it likely caused some damage
to the Russian aircraft as well
to our knowledge well we know that the
aircraft the Russian aircraft did land
I'm not going to go into where they
landed
but again it just demonstrative of uh
very unprofessional unsafe airmanship on
the part of these Pilots one more
question sorry
um will the U.S try to recover this
drone uh so I'm not I don't have
anything right now to provide in terms
of of recovery operations if we have any
updates to provide and we'll be sure to
do that thanks
David
is there video of the incident are you
going to release the video
where in the Black Sea did it happen how
close
to Russian airspace
and did you say that this particular
Reaper was unarmed
again I didn't say whether it was or was
not I'm not going to get into the
particular Mission profile of this
aircraft it was conducting an ISR
Mission
um
in terms of the specifics David I'm not
going to at this point be able to get
more specific other than the Black Sea
region in international airspace well
well clear of of any type of
um yeah it was International airspace
and I'm sorry the other part of your
question the video yes so we are going
through the the declassification process
now and we'll keep you updated on that
front in terms of imagery associated
with this incident
address
I'm laser focused on your question that
was just a very quick one um you haven't
said Reaper but he said Reaper is it
accurate to say it's MQ-9 Reaper
I'm just going to stick with MQ-9 yep
thanks Joe
hi thanks so much Pat um
the uh an MQ-9 potentially contains some
sensitive technology is the U.S military
undertaking any effort to recover the
MQ-9 is it in the is it in the waters of
the Black Sea has Russia recovered it
um is there a U.S naval asset in the in
the region that could undertake that
recovery thanks yeah so uh again I'm not
going to get into the specifics of
what's on this particular aircraft
um other than again it's an ISR platform
uh because of the damage we were in a
position to have to essentially
um crash it into the Black Sea uh to my
knowledge at this point in time
the Russians have not recovered that
aircraft but again in terms of our
recovery efforts don't have any updates
to provide right now I'd refer you to
navier in terms of what assets they may
have in that region thank you
regarding the North Korea's Summit in
Ranchi the Strategic cruise missiles
recently North Korea has announced that
it is possible to monitor nuclear
warhead on a strategic cruise missiles
what is the Readiness of the United
States against the Escalade provocations
such as the nuclear propagation by the
North Korea
let me just make sure I understand
what's the Readiness of the U.S to
respond to a nuclear provocation by
North Korea
well I think we've been very clear that
we're North Korea to employ a nuclear
weapon it would be the end of the North
Korean regime but again our Focus
continues to be on working very closely
with our allies and our partners in the
region to deter aggression to preserve
security and stability in the region and
that will continue to be our our Focus
you go to Carla
a clarification
what did the fighter jet what did he
strike the the MQ-9 with was it the wing
was it yeah uh I can't tell you
specifically what portion of the
aircraft but uh is the fact that it
essentially ran into the MQ-9 okay thank
you and then just separately on Ukraine
there's reports out there from the the
battlefield that the ukrainians are
running out of Munitions they're having
shortages is that a concern for the
Pentagon what's the Pentagon doing to
alleviate that problem yeah so as we've
been doing since the beginning of this
campaign we're continuing to do
everything that we can to ensure that
we're meeting Ukraine's needs whether
it's ammunition whether it's air defense
armor uh you know you've heard us talk
extensively about that tomorrow's
discussion of course will be another
opportunity to bring the International
Community together to focus on Ukraine's
most urgent needs to include ammunition
and so uh again that will continue to be
our focus and and you've heard secretary
Austin and others say that we're
committed to making sure that they have
what they to be successful
system of why they're running out of any
thanks is there an assessment that the
Pentagon has on why they're running out
of ammunition is it because they're just
expending it too fast is it not making
it to the battlefield in time what's
yours yeah really so I'd have to refer
you the ukrainians to talk about their
specific efforts to supply their
individual units again we're working
very closely with them and our
International Partners to get them what
they need and and I think it's also
important to kind of take a step back
and look at the progress that has been
made while recognizing the fact that
there still is a tough fight ahead
particularly as we go into the the
spring and summer and so our our Focus
again is going to be working with
national armoence directors with the
ukrainians to get them the ammunition
they need and get that to the front line
units as quickly as possible let me go
back over to this side of the room yes
sir
sorry
thank you can you guide us through the
timeline of the MQ-9 intercept uh we
have that the aircraft was struck at 703
eastern time but uh how long were the
sukhoys with the aircraft beforehand and
were there any Radio Calls between radio
communications either from the Russians
or from the United States
yeah so on the latter part of your
question no none that I'm aware of
um
and uh I would ask that you go back and
confirm this with UConn but but based on
the information I have here it seems
like uh
approximately
30 to 40 minutes uh they were flying in
the vicinity of this MQ-9 uh and then at
703 is when the
73 a.m Central European Time is when
they collided causing it to crash so
custom
U.S forces has had to bring down the the
aircraft does that mean that the United
States piloted it to the crash site or
was it struck by mslrs yeah we brought
it down
yeah and then also
um is there any U.S naval assets
currently in in black seed again I'd
have to refer you to uh navier for any
details on particular Assets in the
region thank you Laura
um can you talk a little bit more about
the damage to the MQ-9 was it unfiable
and and that's why you had to bring it
down and then can you say a little bit
more about how often this kind of thing
happens in over the Black Sea that
Russian aircraft harass U.S drones and
and other aircraft
yeah so I don't have any statistics in
front of me in terms of intercepts but
again as I highlighted the fact that uh
intercepts of aircraft are not uncommon
in and of themselves it's not obviously
a daily occurrence the vast majority of
those intercepts are what we would
consider safe and professional just
wanting to see what's there right you're
flying alongside it to to be able to see
what's there in this particular case
though again they collided with the
aircraft damaging the propeller and
essentially putting in a situation where
it was unfiable and uncontrollable so we
brought it down thank you time for a few
more go here and then to buff body
hi sir thanks I just wanted to check to
confirm any communication with allies
such as turkey about potential recovery
of the Drone and is there any concern
that Russia could provide the Drone to
Iran if it recovers it uh so that that
would be a hypothetical again Russia
does not have the Drone so that would be
a hypothetical question in terms of
working with allies and partners I don't
have anything to announce here but if
and when we do we'll be sure to let you
know thank you go to fatty and then
we'll come back over here to last you
yep
uh thank you General someone
um I know you don't want to share lots
of information special intelligence
information but are you able to say
whether the MQ-9 was flying
um near Ukraine or near the Crimea
Peninsula and then I believe you said if
I heard right that the Russians did not
recover the uh the Drone however have
you seen any effort by the Russian Navy
to try to recover the Drone thank you
yeah so on your latter question there
Friday I'm not going to get into that
um in terms of where it was flying
um it was well clear of any territory in
Ukraine it was over International in
international airspace over
International water so thank you Nancy
thank you um during secretary Austin's
visit to Egypt he held meetings with
officials even though all press were
banned from covering it past defense
Chiefs when they've been in a similar
situation have refused to proceed given
that the Biden Administration has said
that one of its key pillars in terms of
foreign policy is that one presented
with the a choice between autocrats and
democracies that it stands with
democracies can you help us understand
why the secretary decided to proceed
with those trips given the ban and
should we expect that going forward
thank you thank you so our relationship
with Egypt is obviously a very important
uh strategic partnership uh the
secretary did appreciate the opportunity
to meet with his counterparts and talk
about that I will tell you when it come
when it came to the Press coverage of
that portion having looked further into
it the Egyptians loved lived up to what
they had agreed upon some of the Lessons
Learned out of that was in terms of
making sure that we were on the same
sheet when it came to understanding
press access and so we will continue to
work then
had agreed beforehand that there would
be a ban of journalists we did not agree
to a ban on journalists we agreed to
have official photographers we did have
one reporter come into one of the
sessions but then a portion that was
going to be open to the Press was
subsequently not held and therefore
there was not an opportunity to cover
that but again
sometimes these meetings are are very
small sometimes there's not the
opportunity for media to come in but
again it's something that we've noted
and will continue to work closely with
governments as we visit to ensure that
there's press access
thank you